Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to make some crazy synthetic
music videos.
In machine learning research, view synthesis
papers are on the rise these days.
These techniques are also referred to as NERF
variants, which is a learning-based algorithm
tries that to reproduce real-world scenes
from only a few views.
It is very challenging, look!
In go a bunch of photos of a scene, and the
method has to be able to synthesize new photorealistic
images between these photos.
But this is not the only paper in this area,
researchers are very aware of the potential
here, and thus, a great number of NERF variants
are appearing every month.
For instance, here is a recent one that extends
the original technique to handle shiny and
reflective objects better.
So, what else is there to do here?
Well, look here.
This new one demands not a bunch of photos
from just one camera, but from 16 different
cameras.
That’s a big ask.
But, in return, the method now has tons of
information about the geometry and the movement
of these test subjects, so, is it intelligent
enough to make something useful out of it?
Now, believe it or not, this, in return, can
not only help us look around in the scene,
but even edit it in three new ways.
For instance, one, we can change the scale
of these subjects, add and remove them from
the scene, and even copy-paste them.
Excellent for creating music videos.
Well, talking about music videos.
Do you know what is even more excellent for
those?
Retiming movements…that is also possible.
This can, for instance, improve an okay dancing
performance into an excellent one.
And three, because now we are in charge of
the final footage, if the original footage
is shaky, well, we can choose to eliminate
that camera shake.
Game changer.
Still, it’s not quite the hardware requirement
where you just whip out your smartphone and
start nerfing and editing, but for what it
can do, it really does not ask for a lot.
Look, if we wish to, we can even remove some
of those cameras and still expect reasonable
results.
We lose roughly a decibel of signal per camera.
Here is what that looks like.
Not too shabby!
And all this progress just one more paper
down the line.
And I like the idea behind this paper a great
deal because typically what we are looking
for in a followup paper is trying to achieve
similar results while asking for less data
from the user.
This paper goes into the exact other direction,
and asks what amazing things could be done
if we had more data instead.
Loving it.
And with that, not only neural view synthesis,
but neural scene editing is also possible.
What a time
to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!